j'avais un
film à faire sur toi qu'est-ce que ça montrerait
je ne ferais jamais un film sur moi
des trucs récents ouais je
les aimais beaucoup,
sont-ils spécifiques à cette ville ouais à
certains égards je suppose bien que vous sachiez
qu'il y a d'autres musiciens d'akron trop
chrissy hind des prétendants et des
gens d'autres groupes à new york
donc je suppose que le rock et  le rouleau est juste très
important pour
nous tous à akron c'était peut-être le seul
vrai débouché que vous connaissez donc de
bons musiciens sont venus de vous ont
joué brooke et un quand vous étiez
enfant
non pas vraiment un peu mais vous êtes
le groupe appelé
byzantins maintenant oui quel genre de musique
avez-vous joué
euh difficile à décrire euh
c'est du rock and roll je ne sais pas vraiment
comment le catégoriser
nous avons ouvert nous avons toujours ouvert pour beaucoup de
groupes d'angleterre
à new york comme echo and the bunny man
nouvel ordre une fois pour le psyched  elic furs
je suppose que tu nous as mis quelque part je ne sais pas
c'est très difficile pour moi de catégoriser tu as
déjà ces cheveux quand tu
plaisantais
des cheveux blancs nécro ouais ouais c'est j'ai eu mes
premiers quand j'avais 14 ans.
quelque chose dans ma graisse mon  mère quelque chose de
génétique
je pense qu'elle avait les cheveux complètement blancs
au moment où elle avait 21 ans environ j'étais un peu
plus lent mais
mon oncle elle a un frère jumeau pareil
et il était comme sa
femme c'était facile de travailler avec des producteurs japonais
très facile  était génial parce qu'ils ont dit que
nous vous donnions l'argent pour faire le film,
nous ne voulons rien vous dire
sur la façon de faire le film et
nous ne voulons même pas le voir
tant qu'il n'est pas terminé, donc c'était vraiment
bien ils sont juste
restés  loin, ils m'ont observé travailler mais
n'ont jamais fait de commentaires
sur ce que je faisais, donc pour moi, c'était
parfait
deux de vos trois premiers films réalisés par la
loi et plus étrange que le paradis
étaient des films cultes et vous pouvez
considérer comme un
garçon merveilleux mais le dernier  un train mystérieux
n'était pas  que bien reçu dans le calme l'
année dernière pourquoi je veux dire ça ne me dérange pas les mauvaises critiques
si elles sont intelligentes je les aime beaucoup
mieux qu'une bonne critique qui n'est pas
intelligente
alors mais cette année j'étais tellement occupé et un peu
je n'ai vraiment pas lu  eux
et je ne suis pas vraiment sûr moi-même j'aime
le film je pense que c'est une bonne
étape pour moi c'est parfait mais
je ne suis pas vraiment sûr que peut-être que certaines personnes
n'ont vraiment pas aimé le film
qui est valable ou peut-être que certaines personnes ont
juste pensé  j'ai eu trop d'
attention
avant et j'ai pensé qu'il était temps de savoir comment le
décririez-vous
si je voulais la
société de production
tout se passe à memphis cela se
passe le même soir
et tous les personnages se retrouvent dans
le même hôtel
le  la même nuit mais aucun d'eux ne se rencontre jamais
mais au delà de ça c'est difficile pour moi de
décrire c'est vrai que l'idée d'avoir trois
histoires dans le même film
t'a été donnée par la ronde de max
office
que tu vois quand tu habites
la france en 75
c'est en partie vrai quand
j'écrivais d'abord le scénario de train mystère et
je commençais par les personnages pas
l'histoire
il y avait deux choses qui m'ont influencé l'
un était un livre de william faulkner
appelé les palmiers sauvages
qui est un livre où deux
histoires distinctes sont racontées
avec des chapitres alternés  ils ne
s'interconnectent jamais
et ils sont complètement différents, ce que je
pensais être une très belle
forme et l'autre chose était que je
regardais à nouveau beaucoup de films de maxo idiots
principalement parce que j'étais intéressé par son
genre de montage d'
élégance à la manière  ses films sont
construits
vous avez des souvenirs de cette période euh
ouais j'ai de bons souvenirs je n'avais pas d'argent
j'avais vécu dans une pièce avec
un autre de mes amis
mais j'ai mes meilleurs souvenirs vraiment
passer du temps au cinéma
et voir  des films, c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai vraiment
décidé que je voulais faire des films
avant que je m'intéresse le plus à la
littérature et que je voulais être écrivain
ou espérer être écrivain que pensez-vous
de nous  cinéma aujourd'hui comment
réagissez-vous devant hollywood le genre de
films que j'aime ont tendance à être de deux
extrêmes j'aime les
films b j'aime euh les films cultes
j'aime
vous connaissez les films d'horreur et les films de science-fiction
et en même temps j'aime
les films soi-disant plus artistiques
vous savez
j'aime les films de jean-marie straub et
jacqueline vet par exemple donc j'ai tendance
à aimer ces deux extrêmes
et ce qu'il y a entre eux ne
m'intéresse pas tant que ça
et j'espère que mes films  avoir une sorte d'
influence croisée de ces deux choses
votre film est lancé en europe avant
les états
ne vous sentez-vous pas beaucoup plus comme un nouveau
réalisateur européen
j'ai l'impression d'être dans un tout petit bateau
quelque part au milieu de l'atlantique
donne-moi un scoop quel sera ton prochain
coup
c'est un rasta de science-fiction
[Musique]
bleu